weil meine damen und herren ist eine
plattform die nicht mehr existiert warum
reagiert denn überhaupt nicht auf fragen
über fragen die das universum
beschäftigt meine lieben freunde aber
ich habe mir gedacht heute zur feier des
tages was können wir denn heute ist ja
auch komplett egal ich würde euch auf
jeden fall sehr gerne herzlich gehalt
hat einfach dein maul luca ich habe
jetzt ein video entdeckt was heißt mainz
der teenie vom endingen toll also weins
die mich daran hindern alles
hinzuschmeißen in einer gewissen form
ich würde sagen wir schauen uns die
weins einfach mal an und jetzt kommen
bei einer reaktion auf wein luca
reagiert auf wein also war in die
plattform nicht das getränk
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich weiß warum weint todes das war ja
mal überhaupt nicht lustig ich schwöre
euch ich kann nie wieder durch den
supermarkt gehen und sich an zu denken
[Musik]
ich liebe es wenn irgendwas so auf
spannend aufgebaut wird wie
beispielsweise ich hier freunde wir
sehen hier dx files ein alien auf dem
laufband als jetzt also mal ganz im
ernst dass von beginn also den ersten
wein das erste video von seinen
kommentaren habe ich überhaupt nicht
mehr statt
aber die anderen beiden haben jetzt
schon sich für mich gelohnt dieses video
anzuschauen
the fucking kartoffel an einem
ventilator oben an so ein propeller
ventilator und sich zu beginn noch ganz
leicht dann ich weiß sie bestimmen bin
also klar bin ich ja aber das ist genau
mein humor
die kann man nicht so behindert er
innerhalb einer erfahrung wie dumm kann
man denn sein
den lässt
ich muss alles riesig doch warum ist
diese plattform tod alter warum hat es
diese plattform nicht geschafft bestehen
zu bleiben das ist so lustig alter
ich frage mich immer ob solche sachen
angestrebte sind oder nicht
ihr seht schon freuen ich habe hier so
eine schöne weiße rudi under steht
lucile drauf ist der bis 2011 an einen
kanal drauf gemacht habe ihr fragt euch
wahrscheinlich haye
wann kommt er denn in den shop gute
frage übermorgen freitag 15 uhr also
steuergeld freunde diesen rudi könnte da
nämlich kauft mit einer tollen gemütlich
großen kapuze also haye
paul-luca als ich verstehe nicht wie
kleine kinder schon solche beleidigungen
sagen können und dann noch so frech sein
können könnt ihr euch noch daran
erinnern wo ich auf diese kleine
amerikanerin namens nelke reagiert habe
du willst so ein ekelhafter mensch das
war auch so ein kleines freches
verlogenes mädchen und dann sicher
solche kinder und enkel oder erziehung
habt ihr glaube ich nicht die haben sich
die haben es einfach gepasst
die damit sogleich einen kleinen er
wurde mir mal zugeschickt als sich luca
reagiert gemacht habe und ich dachte
dass er irgend so eine junge und ich
habe mich die ganze zeit und gedanken
darüber gemacht hey was ist wenn
irgendwann kommt und sagt ich soll alle
videos unternehmen wo ich den rheinpark
reingepackt habe also von wegen er hatte
keinen bock darauf dass seine gesichter
so in meinen videos gezeigt wird und so
und jetzt ist ja einfach in diesem video
drin
[Musik]
jürgen au so war es damals die musikerin
es gab immer diese leute die meinten ja
wir können voll gut singen irgendwann
sind wir denn michael jackson 3.7 und
dann gab es mich
ich war wie er quasi
und ja dachte ja einfach nur halt's maul
wird im kunstkurs cancer ich dachte erst
dass hier wäre so ganze mal abbrechen
und die rutsch vielleicht hinten raus
und dann 70 die komplett los
der nabu elektroschock also weit
freundlich habt ihr auch noch irgendwie
sonne längst schon geregelt sondern
schublade hier wenn ihr wenn ihr mal
wollte das nicht eventuell einen
elektroschocker challenge mache dann
dass man leichter und bei 60
[Applaus]
1000 m
ich habe jetzt schon angst vor ehrlich
gesagt also schafft dass man bitte nicht
denken ich wenig und die dame ein oder
hey das ist so bescheuert wie kommt man
auf solche idee dass wir
hundertprozentig bei der genau in dem
moment das foto gemacht hat einen
kratzer foto bon gewesen hat die kenne
ich doch schon
[Gelächter]
nein nein nein
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich habe mir
schon gedacht in dem moment wo sie hier
runter fährt die schuldenbremse die ist
der komplett alleine drehen sie kann ich
bremsen und dann alter schwede
gc muss nicht mehr zusammen aus
[Musik]
sie machen einfach selbst mit dem
taschenrechner schöner blick übrigens
auch gerade hier das mit dem
taschenrechner so könnte auch meine
mutter sei okay
[Musik]
also die stellt sich vor und sagte sie
seien
genauso sehe ich auch meinen klub aus
ich habe mich glaube ich mehr druck als
er aber er zeigt rosol verlassen
[Musik]
könnte auch mein leben als in sein wie
kommt man auf solche ideen
[Musik]
ihr seid auch genau passt es gibt hier
den ball ab diese musikalische
untermalung echt nie mehr stelle ihr
seid göttlich was sowas angeht
anders stelle sich das heutige wird
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat um dieses video geht halt noch
sieben minuten wie gesagt das gerne mal
ein leichter bei 60.000 likes werde ich
einerseits irgendwann mal was mit diesem
elektroschocker gerät machen und
eventuell auch noch mal weiter auf
dieses video hier reagieren also zeit
für mich dass eventuell noch mal machen
soll sonst wie zu beginn schon gesagte
luz usd bis 2011 und andere merchandise
und klamotten und so weiter und sofort
kommen in zwei tagen am freitag um 15
uhr in meinem shop und jetzt ich zeige
euch mal die top adresse